-Now I thought
I'd share some of my favorite,
"My Drunk Story" tweets
from you guys, here we go.
This first one is from
@ellenmlauri. She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurred speech ]
Is my special day.
-My birthday.
-[ Normal voice ] This one's
from @ahskidmore. He says...
[ Laughter ]
You almost got there, dude.
-Yeah almost, man.
-He almost made it.
-Yeah.
That's the old college try.
-[ Laughs ] This one's from
@Jordan White 4. She says...
[ Laughter ]
You're my best friend.
I am my best friend.
This one's from @buntybaggins.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-She says...
There you go!
[ Laughter ]
The trifecta.
-Bunty!
-How embarrassing was that?
-Hee-haw
-[ Grunts, groans ]
Wow.
-Oh, Bunty.
-This one's from @FoggyDew1310.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] He was up waiting
for him.
-[ Jimmy laughs ]
He didn't even get in that.
He didn't even
get in his own house.
This one's from @maddie shea524.
She says...
It says max pizza sticks
and how to undrunk yourself.
[ Laughter ]
That's fantastic.
Pizza sticks?
I never heard of that.
This one's from @GreenApple2.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
Hey, man.
This one is from, uh,
@debAURAhhh. She says...
[ Laughter ]
Hi, I-I'm missing.
I think I'm missing.
Uh, this one is from
@thePolishista or thepolishista?
Polishista, like maybe she's
into nail polish?
-Polishing? Like Pledge
furniture polish?
-Oh, yeah, man.
Yeah thepolishista.
Or Polish.
-She loves Poland.
[ Light laughter ]
Uh, she says...
[ Laughter ]
What?! That's too much.
You've had too much.
You've had too much to drink,
I'm sorry.
This one's from @mc 125.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
And that's it.
That's it.
♪♪♪♪
-Wow.
-Brad Pitt.
Got a Brad Pitt tattoo.
Absolutley I think.
-No.
-Fantastic.
This last one's from
@boss hogg57. He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's a win right there.
And there you have it, those are
tonight's show hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.